hi everybody
i just wanted to catch up on the uh ea
play live
the 2021 spotlight of the ea originals
heart's independent studio stream
uh because i've not seen it so i was
gonna watch it anyway and then i saw
that it's actually quite long and i was
like why don't i just stream it i'm
going to eat some food it's going to be
really loud in the microphone
and i also have i tried to fix my
shutter speed but i can't
so the flickering i'm aware of we know
that it is happening
um tantv this is one of ea's uh e3 shows
they're calling it the spotlight series
they have i think
three of them there was already a an fps
focused one
this is focused on the ea originals
program which i am a very big fan of and
try to talk about pretty often as a very
good thing
uh that ea does um
because and i have had a couple of indie
devs tell me this wasn't the case for
them
but more have confirmed it than not that
basically what they do
is fund the game they recoup marketing
costs but otherwise the indie studios
get to keep the ip
they get to have full creative control
um it's it's basically like ea helps pay
for indie studios to make games at an ea
level
with ea's marketing um without
most of the evil downsides that come
with that like you know
retaining ip restrictions on the studios
they have so much freedom
i think this is such a fantastic program
that every other
ea play live i've been so confused as to
why they didn't talk about that part of
it
more because i think it's so good um so
i'm glad to see that they're actually
focusing an entire conference on it
because it is a really wonderful thing
that um
that ea does uh so yeah that's why we're
watching this hopefully see some cool
games that ea are supporting from indie
studios which is the whole plan who get
to keep being indie studios
even outside of ea um
no name.number it is not any led light
in the room it is just the ceiling
lights
nothing i can do about it unless we were
pitch black literally every single light
in this room has the
the shutter issue unfortunately so yeah
um i'm gonna eat uh hopefully it's not
too loud
and just watch this conference because
i'm a very big fan and i
um you know wanna show more people
cool indie games and they generally have
some pretty good variety i think they
generally get pretty creative with them
so
um i'm just going to ask you guys to
tell me if the levels are terrible when
this starts because i
wasn't able to test that
my mic is definitely picking up the
eating
zoink uh dope the world of random
bends truthfully this looks pretty zoink
loved it takes two played that with
ethan my worst performing youtube video
of the last 12 months
it's a really good game go watch that
video please
that's just me but get yourself a crew
i also really like knockout city
[Music]
you want me to turn the sound up for the
ea side i'll put my microphone
they should be scared of us
hi i am todd martins the gaming
journalist for the los angeles times and
welcome to the eba spotlights here it's
unexpected this is the second panel in
which ea is connecting you
with the games you love and the people
who make them leading up to ea play on
july 22nd
ea invited me to the volume on the video
that doesn't mean what you think it
means
do you mean on the um i was happy to do
this a lot of the games
independent space are some of my
favorite games might be too loud now
games that tend to innovate both
technologically and on the storytelling
front ea originals was founded in 2015
with the
mission statement to find cultivate
build successful partnerships with some
of the world's leading independent
studios
um the first game under the ea regionals
banner i believe was unravel from
coldwood studios it was one of my
favorite games of that year
a number of these games have been
recognized by the baftas and other
industry organizations
um so with that let's uh dig into
couldn't be more different energy
is greg miller today who are working on
projects under the ea originals banner
thank you everyone for joining us i'm
super excited to talk to all of you i
think we've got kind of a just
look at him look at him go this is a
different sort of some different ideas
um i just figured we'd do a real quick
intro he was uh just very true
the last time that i saw
as well and then just real quickly say
the first game you ever fell
in love with so uh joseph i'll throw it
over to you
yes my name is joseph harris and i'm the
creative
uh director and a founder at hazelite
pretty much
i've actually background in the in films
i've done uh
microphones with movies pretty much for
two years
and uh started making games for 10 years
ago
and my first game i fell in love with
have to be super mario bruce
one even if i played actually started
playing earlier with the atari one
uh well it's a classic and probably one
of the greatest first levels of all time
um olav uh let's hear a little bit uh
from you
and uh over at zoink and some of the
maybe non-game stuff you've
dabbled i really like zoink big fan i've
not met him
and i'm the creative director and the
writer on lost in random
and um well my first uh big
love within video games was baldur's
gate with its huge story
and uh the possibility of creating your
own story in in i think we have less
okay i think i learned english playing
that game too so and originally i'm a
comic artist
and a storyboarder when i started
working with games oh was i right about
saying the zoink game was a zombie game
my idea is explaining quickly with with
uh fast drawings um
our team that's probably the game silver
rain studio
there's a new studio and but also we're
not here to necessarily talk about this
spinning depth
flipping sort of talk a little bit about
uh your background
and um starting uh the studio
yeah hi um my name is abubak assalam
um the creative director of our
undisclosed game
at silver ring games originally actor um
also done producing as well within the
film industry and the tv industry
but yeah decided to get into games
because i mean i love games
one game that i fell in love with the
sonic the hedgehog on the sega that's a
pretty slick game
hi um i'm melissa phillips i'm head of
studio at silver rain games
a studio that started someone being like
in march sonic
it's pretty slick it's very funny to me
you have backgrounds in both
music psychology you've got degrees in
those uh
of which i weirdly use none of them
but all of them every single day in my
job
um and first game that i really loved
and brought me into games was probably
oh either theme hospital or populist the
beginning
awesome and guha congrats on the launch
of
knockout city uh pretty recently this
year so you have a pretty wide-ranging
background as well
um i think a lot of people know some of
your background in the tech side of
games but
uh yeah just give us a quick sort of
interview that was actually
um your world and your expertise
and um the first game you fell in love
that's so cool uh thank you todd
it's funny if i talk about my non-games
background it's really going to very
early childhood you know karthik my
brother and i started
our first game company vicarious visions
when we were in high school i was 14 and
he was 15.
this dude started vicarious visions
learning how to make a video game and we
it's um what we've played man okay
how you constructed every aspect of the
creative process playing all the roles
when there are no instruction books on
how to do it that was just so
fascinating and continues to drive us
uh and so with vellum studios our
mission is really to find those new
types of interactivity
that the people that are really
unexpected people really wonder where
they come from and you really need to
get your hands on them
uh to be able to understand that now
back in the day what really got me
interested
was a game called starfly 2. actually i
played star flight 1 after
two it was a pc game uh ms-dos
at the time but it just showed with even
is it the first game you fell in love
with was that the question
the imagination and make non-linear
narrative where you really put the
uh player i think it was banjo-kazooie
oh peppermint is the center of an
adventure
the first game i think i ever played was
motor race but i'm not sure so much for
us
so i don't want to put the uh the new
studio on the spot
but um i guess i'm going to do that a
little bit um abu
uh just talk a little bit about you know
you said you've loved games but your
decision to
you know really want to express that
love by starting a studio
um you know the journey from starting
that studio to
working with ea originals um and we'll
start there
yeah no i think look i mean i i think
there's a lot of um
power in storytelling in games because i
feel like
you got the audience it's a very
interesting way to produce this
characters on the screen
or you know really kind of shaping the
story that's going on but they have to
get them
a screen and two cameras in each of
their setups the way i kind of see it
i'm a storyteller right so it's just
another way or another voice or another
platform to tell those stories on
it's it's a great journey because we're
just all a bunch of kids wanting to
play storytellers right and um yeah it's
that's what it is fabio that is a really
good
first game zelda three between us we've
got uh
and how games were made and the people
behind them but actually being on the
other side now
uh it's been a whole learning experience
the last year has been a
baptism of fire i guess as we make
mistakes but we
we learn from them and i think that's
what's really lovely about the studio
with silver rain is that
we really value the team that we have
it's an incredible team
just over 30 people now um and still
growing
we've always got jobs on the website but
they said to check that out right man 30
people already
damn like i remember it's one of our
learnings jason
30 people over here yeah yeah i remember
when i did brothers we were like uh we
were
ten people not eight or nine people yeah
yeah big that's a very impressive game
for them too because i have a bit kind
of the same bracket from a movie i just
want to make something clear to add a
little bit what you were talking about
for me these two are two entirely
different mediums it's
very important to remember that because
uh one is interactive and one is passive
because one thing i've learned is that
games are not movies he's writing
something that's the opposite
we speak about this oh look uh one on
this week's episodes play watch listen
have two entirely different
uh mediums you could get inspired from
each other but the way for instance to
write a book or to write a screen
a screenplay are two entirely different
ways of writing
yeah and this is what we need to do for
for games as well so i'm a super
optimist
in impactful stories and uh i mean
emotional impacts on on people in the
future well we're just there
we're we're just like scratching the
surface you know uh we had a
dark period in games and then occurred
between like 2000 approximately in 2010
but there was a notion among companies
that you would see the film
and then play the game i guess they
tried to do that a little bit i don't
feel like that was a consistent doc
period
but with mechanics like [ __ ] that was
based on the movie was actually supposed
to be pretty good and there would be a
total mismatch and this is sort of the
big downfall of narrative experiences of
the past it makes a lot of sense also to
tell to tell the story in video games
because you're always
following you like the interactivity
you're always looking at the
step-by-step experience of the player
and like
really immersing yourself in what will
they actually experience what will they
see
genuinely we speak about this a lot in
this week's play watch listen for me
that makes so much
sense the first 30 minutes is off topic
of course yeah
the latter half really pulls this in a
situation in a different way i think and
and it's helped me a lot to to learn
about fabulous work
longer scripts because you have to fill
in the in the details you can't
leave anything to the imagination uh
until
until it's in the player's hands yeah
why'd you look like a blob of clay
wanna change back then you need to fix
your relationship
you know um it takes two uh joseph is a
really fascinating game
such a good game um it deals with a lot
of grown-up topics
yet at times it feels very silly very
wacky and at times the gameplay almost
feels like a metaphor of this couple's
relationship so i just talk about you
know sort of the challenge of telling
what is
you know what on the surface is a very
sort of you know classic story about a
couple
um but then making that come through
ver via oh bobby i still stream on
twitch i tend to do any conferences
like editorial streams are on youtube
you can because it's part of the story
video games you don't want to end up in
a situation where you play a game
i mean you could play some games
sometimes we're almost waiting for the
next cut scene so the idea is to use it
the mechanics as part of the story i
think it's a little bit underused in
gaming now and i think we can use it way
more often i mean it takes two you have
many situations
sometimes i strongly agree i dislike for
also it could be that you know whatever
they meet if they meet
like a hammer from a toolbox that they
own or something you're actually playing
so you're playing what you're seeing and
immediately it's a really good game
the mechanics are part of the
storytelling you could also use the
mechanics
in a sense to convince an emotion for
the player i mean for instance
the first game i did brothers you i mean
i'm gonna spoil it literally here's the
guy from the game
but in the end you're actually literally
like a playing
uh like like burying your big big
brother that dies in the end a little
bit so
it's almost and i would say the opening
of last of us where you carry your girl
and runs with her like everything like
you're using the mechanic to to to push
your storytelling and that is a bit
underused sometimes and i think we can
push that even more and that's what
we are tased i want to keep pushing i so
strongly agree with everything you just
said
that's super important to me
olav um lost in random looks uh
beautiful
thank you curious to hear you talk a
little bit about
and let sort of you know people watching
know sort of about
the tone of that game you know the big
picture sort of yeah i agree
um but also sergeant what's good
there is room for both yes but i still
think video games are not
randomness that you guys are taking
advantage of what they are just yet and
are instead still very much film-like in
a lot of places we have so far
it's a dark fairy tale it's an accident
and you play as this girl
who grows up in in this uh there are
three wards
in the land of random one word for each
side of a six-sided dice
and this dice belong to an evil queen of
course
and and she she rules she creates these
weird systems to keep these places in
check
and so every world has its own theme
when we first started with the project
we wanted to do something darker so a
fairy tale
that was a little bit darker than the
rest of the stuff we'd already made and
um we tried out
drawing all these different characters
and concepts and but it wasn't until
this painting of
of a dice and her girl appeared that we
knew that
there is something to explore the
concept of a living dice getting um
little nightmares vibes from this for
sure attractive to us
another stay was like a gameplay be like
metroidvania
and what is just randomly i think
everything revolves around and then
grows out of it i think it's called
flipping theme and the gameplay
was more of a puzzle uh concept
very natural almost like a
point-and-click adventure out of it
that had a perspective too like if you
have it i have an idea that it's weird
and
and you're installing this definitely
stick with the idea and just stay with
it and okay we're not sure what what it
will be and
but it's important to let yourself to be
like i don't know let's not know
together for a while and explore this
weird idea and
see where it goes i was just going to
add in actually
everything that everybody said so this
is kind of like a roundtable and it's
exactly why
i love working in games and what makes
the games industry
really special my fear and actually
something to perhaps pose back to the
group is that
i always worry about whether we can hold
on to this authenticity
as a as an industry uh because the more
interested
that business and other industries
become in us
uh the more at risk we are of losing
that authenticity i think we're having a
sort of golden age at the moment where
this freedom is allowed and
people like myself uh can start to see
themselves coming through in these
stories
um and i i hope that we can keep that
alive and keep that going and that that
authenticity isn't lost
or merged you're right it's a medallion
around
they're doing their best exactly why
we're in indie studios because
that authenticity is worth the struggle
it's worth fighting for
and it takes an independent mindset
to really push the boundaries uh to be
able to take a risk
to come out of a typical business model
or a typical franchise stream to create
a unique emotional experience for
players
and we have we've made active choices to
have that flexibility
and it comes along with it some kind of
burden as well it's not as predictable
it's not as bankable uh it's uh
um you know you know a lot of the risks
meet with failure
and that has to be a learning experience
and that sounds a little trite
but every indie game cycle involves that
i wouldn't
be too worried actually to have i think
if you have a
uh when you have a strong vision what
you believe in i think actually it's the
opposite the other industries around us
i mean if you look at the movies if
we're talking about that
uh they will soon realize how great
storytelling is in gaming and
actually are realizing that's why james
don't worry there's nothing to fear here
there will come i know the movie
business they will come crawling and
understand how beautiful gaming is
that's gonna take a while it's all about
like uh i love your optimism but it's
gonna take a while and a lot of game
writing still isn't great here
a lot of it is still just you high one
two assists
with you gameplay that's really cool
because when people talk about that game
like the gameplay comes first and then
the narrative comes later there are a
few studios who do
writing first
um like the tone of that game the way it
looked the way it felt
it was very bright it was it was really
getting a hand to the player it felt
very welcoming but i have only played it
once i didn't feel the need to go back
we don't necessarily put that up front
we talk about it as
as a dodgeball as a mechanic as a you do
this you fight this you xyz
we don't necessarily talk about the uh
that's a very good point jason who said
uh for example
hades in return use actual gameplay and
they did it very well
uh discovery of balance they're
obviously very similar games um
um some kind of a little bit easier for
that type of game but
something new a game worth making i
still think spec up's the worst
that's the question it's the best
example of pairing we found this kind of
throwing and catching you know just
imagine you know when we were playing
throwing and catching you know some of
us do
i do it all the time with my children
for example but you know through
childhood it's one of the universal
narratives
when you do throwing and catching and
special things with it in all sports
it makes you feel energetic it energizes
you it's a joy when you catch the tough
past
and so we said okay this is the start of
something joyful competition
we don't see that in games that much
let's build on that knockout city is
very satisfying the world gives us the
grounding knockout city we invented it
as a place to say
how do we experience this joyful
competition
a world that's sort of the way we
imagine it
should be inclusive welcoming uh
everything is settled with epic
dodgeball battles what's his accent
so even if you're outgunned and
outnumbered
with your skill i can't tell where to
actually make a difference
in the us he would be from even if you
get defeated you're ready to get back
into it
because you feel like you weren't beaten
you feel like you're ready to be back in
the competition
some distinction emotional profile all
the decisions
from a design standpoint from a world
building standpoint
from a music design standpoint maybe
he's been in multiple countries we're
going to have some backstory what's
happened to my accent
that the and we don't explicitly do it
we don't use narrative techniques but
it's in the world
and it's in the vo uh it's to be able to
make people feel like they're grounded
in this and they can be part of that
experience so
i mean i know what a north american
accent sounds like it's not that
interesting
like interesting but really they're only
successful if they elicit
unless uh something like this it's
something about his lower jaw
i'm here to play which i would think is
regional and feel something different
so we use different techniques and
narrative to be narrative
like it's definitely like a boo i was
kind of curious to
hear your thoughts a little bit um just
we've talked to you in the last few
minutes about some like high-level
topics about
emotion in games and marrying uh
studio i know gameplay all curious to
hear what you're working on when you're
ready to
talk about it but what would you sort of
say like
maybe i'm imagining it would be maybe
like a thesis for the studio
in terms of where you guys want to put a
focus yeah i mean look it does start
with story right and it starts
with with it it starts there but it's
quickly followed by
again the medium in which you're telling
it which is interactivity
i think you know for us as well it's
we're always we're always asking
about that players journey about that
players experience and that's why
it's funny whenever i whenever we talk
about the idea of like you know emotion
and games and stuff
like that like i i don't think that
that's not the aim man like the aim is
to just
is to deliver a brilliant experience
like you don't go to the theater to go
and
you know watch a play which is supposed
to be sad oh you go watch a good play
if it's sad and it's happy that's
fantastic and um
and it's it look in it's it's a it's
tough man like
making games isn't easy it's true it's a
hard
hard process but that's what's so
brilliant and beautiful about it because
i
i truly believe that through the through
the difficulty of finding something and
hitting it right
you end up basically sharing that
difficulty
and that hard you know that hard journey
with the person playing it they feel
that
and they are and with other studios
which we also talk about this week's
episode
and here's the kicker like ideas are
cheap everybody has ideas
western canadian mom has ideas that
makes a dog i definitely didn't hear any
indian i know you guys said that in the
chat but i was like
everybody has the capability of being
creative in some way
the hard part i think of game making is
how do we
choose which ideas we take forward out
of this
mad pool of ideas that we have
and i think the craft comes from being
able to
select the best sometimes just the most
feasible ideas not even the best we
sometimes have to
kill sometimes it's got to be cheap to
save money so you can do other expensive
things
how do we prioritize what goes forwards
what feels good
um and the craft comes from actually
making those ideas and i don't think
skateboard is going to show up here
and making sure that i'm sorry to create
the game
it is not in the original it takes two i
went into that game
you know the pandemic was still very
much a mystery here in america at that
time
and then there was the other idea of
like i was also going through a
relationship that was falling apart
so i didn't necessarily i was nervous
about playing
it takes two because i was like do i
want to play a game about a divorce at
the same time
like that game is such a good game silly
and fun and inventive
like i never once felt necessarily quote
unquote sad i just felt
exuberance at like learning about these
characters
someone asked me like uh is this kind of
a relation
you know shift uh to help you it's kind
of kind of a therapy session or
something
the funny part is that we saw already in
the testing already when
playing the game that if you're in a
relationship that wasn't so good it was
quite clear actually because you really
had to
you know it's almost like the experience
are in the couch that's almost also how
we design the game so
so if you if you're playing this with
your partner and your communication is
interesting then you're not going to be
able to play the game that good so not
only would you
will the game be be you know not go have
the same fluidness in the game
may say something about your own
relationship that something is not
working
and from that perspective we're seeing i
mean reactions i wouldn't say
i don't know how accurate or true they
are of people actually fun
creatives asking each other to get
married to the game
and that's quite cool actually if it's
true i don't know but that's how they
write to us i have to accept that it
is a true thing but it's a good way to
get to know like
where you are at in your relationship
because obviously communication is key
i mean yes it takes two it takes you to
communicate as well
guha i wanted to sort of transition a
little bit and
hear your thoughts on with sort of a
game like knockout city which is going
to be an ongoing game and it's going to
evolve
you know you and the team are maybe
thinking about adding some story but
keeping that sort of
lively and keeping that constantly sort
of yeah they they all get creative
freedom and funding they really do
i imagine that this is not very serious
what's so cool about it
it's just genuinely indie dev's talking
about being in devs on ea's platform
yeah i really feel like
always great and then
see how the community responds and
embraces it and evolve it with a
community
and so from the very early onset it was
designed as a sort of a live service
product which
finds an audience and then follows the
audience and evolves it and continues to
surprise
so we have a slew of content that's
actually in production that will be
available
and the idea is why did they choose that
cut
he just goes with new things that can
change up the play now we'll have
the play what what is your accent lobby
where you team up with friends
uh before you get into a game instead of
waiting in a menu to be able to find out
if they show up and
you know that kind of thing and so it
was really interesting you know the
early
prototypes of knockout cities started um
in 2017 so a little over four years
before it was launched
that's a long longish cycle for a game
but it feels
like an indie game still at the starting
uh line you know the launch is the start
you know there's this conversation
always in pop culture amongst fans and
amongst creators that it's like
everything has to be based on ip and in
the independent game world
this is where all of like originality is
um you know and i was kind of curious oh
love to hear
you know you talk a little bit about the
studio and deciding
on lost and random and like what was the
sense of
you know because as melissa was saying
earlier like everybody has ideas
so what was the sense of like this is
something that we can experiment with
both as a studio that we can experiment
with
as artists but something we feel good
about you know committing
you know x amount of years of our lives
to
me personally of course there's great
value in looking at the market and what
people are playing right now but people
won't be playing what they are now
in a couple of years so why not just go
with what's fun and
weird uh in in the moment it's it's a
it's a very art
driven studio always has been zoink uh
driven by klaus
i'd love to go there klaus i've met he's
wonderful he's super usually the guy
like
we're sweating and finishing the
previous game he's like guys what do you
think about a giant ghost in vr and
we're like yeah we've got to finish this
thing first but sounds
great give us some time and digest it
abu already said also where yeah he's
one of the kids
playing like like oh then this guy comes
and he he fights this guy and they're
they're brothers actually and why
like that kind of energy you want to
bring to to creating video games i think
so yeah just just uh go with that
creativity they're one of those studios
wherever yes
it started i'll play everything
and a saga and you know we looked at
grim fairy tales and
over the garden wall and stuff like that
and even if the idea
at first makes everyone go oh really
hmm okay dice with legs and arms and
okay let's taste it for a bit and and
like don't be afraid of the can of worms
yeah i guess it's the message i just
wanted to say like i love him that is
actually a
perfect um sort of analogy in a way of
what
the original studies do in regards of
like
they're not afraid to take a risk like
you can you will come in with a crazy
idea and you'll come in with something
quite quite out there something that's
not really necessarily been seen
or sounds dangerous or sounds hard and
they will be like you know what
go for it they give you that space and
room to play which is so
so beautiful i just get very excited if
i'm ever in a writer's room and somebody
says spaces
crazy ideas like you're like yes let's
go at the moment out here
called raised by wolves and the first
two episodes of the season
[Laughter]
thanks the first who is he thank you
very much
so somebody said he was fired thank you
well no but like look the first two
episodes right
were directed by ridley scott and it's
it's terrifying
it's one of those things where it's like
you you're
you're going head-to-head with this
goliath right but
the beauty of what he was able to
capture on set was he allowed you room
to play
he allowed your room to be bold he
allowed you room to just
explore which is so rare sometimes
i think every publisher should do this
actually focus
on creative crazy games that does
something very different
but doesn't have the major financial
risk because i understand like you want
to put a hundred million dollars
something that's crazy
he did do a race whatever that is those
smaller games that are crazy and more
creative adventures than an hp mac and
it looks like he is primarily
functioning and working and then you can
actually inspire the triple a
also as well you know joseph he has
worked look at that and say
you know it's not just about inspiration
it's about saying
right they're looking for all new novel
concepts can start small
you know it's the kind of the simple as
a hard concept
you know when we wrote our if you write
the concept for knockout city on a piece
of paper people believe
like i'm going to play this action game
with dodge balls
give me a gun i think i know how to do
that um and so that's typically the
response for that
but the concept itself can be proven out
at a small scale
and the concept itself can grow and it
can be grown
by the same by you joseph in your
context by us
from a knockout city standpoint but it's
the ability to recognize that something
special
but the developer recognizes but then
also you know the label should
recognize as well and believe that one
of the things that was most impressive
to us was that
um after we had found this core and
you know we thought hey this this is a
good game i'm feeling what i need to
feel
with this thing we shopped it around and
there's something unique about the
uh originals team in ea everybody played
everybody all the way to the executive
that's awesome
uh a team of the egg played before we
said huh that's the right partner for us
uh because they could understand that
vision they could see it and they said
okay we're ready to take a risk not a
huge risk but we're ready to take a risk
and serious sequential bets because this
game needs to come out yeah that's
awesome
knockout city was also kind of a risk
for the studio as well like you guys had
to create
uh pretty much i also noticed that
airport project the airport
i mean i reckon it's uh nothing like it
before that's how they they sent them
or whatever that's how they made sure
they did the production is that
everybody had to wear it
i think it would be sponsored but i
think it would be like a play and an
audio solution
were there many physics options a very
interesting production or herself could
be
themselves could be become the ball also
i just think it's really cool
ever changing i like that the ea low
companies is doing this it's not a
flashy automatically relies on a series
of sizzle reels it's not
hey buy these indie games hey give some
micro transactions you're on the east
and west coast
it's andy dubs talking about the games
they maybe are playing together we're
playing against each other
it's an incredibly hard problem to solve
and we couldn't find conventional
approaches to do it
so we had to invent the computer
language to be able to
allow us to do reversible computation at
scale and that's pretty much how we
approach problem solving here available
it's sort of like
you know if this game needs to be made
we're going to figure out how to do it
i just want to add on even if he keeps
jumping in
you know all right joseph let's go let
me tell you this the amount of stuff we
added on to make an
online game also function in split
screen with so much variety in game
mechanics it's
absolute madness uh actually i know that
we made more tools that unreal are using
from us
than we are using from them about that
cool thing about unreal is the huge
challenge to create an online game i
mean not not
i mean especially in split screen where
you see the lag and everything so
there's
i think i think whoever has an engine
you need to do a lot of add-ons that
fits your vision and game
like you're saying yeah i know i was
curious joseph
um if bean an indie studio if you felt
that that made that task
um of having to sort of invent those
tools
even using a popular game engine and
just being independent if that made it
you know easier for you guys like as a
studio to sort of
shift directions at whims or because it
seems like it is a very big of a mission
statement for your studio to
do sort of co-op sort of games i
wouldn't call us
in the india right now i would say we
are a bit i mean we are more a triple i
as they say today not not just a regular
indie so we have
more knowledge our developers are more
like you know a more kick-ass they know
more how to do stuff we know more how to
solve stuff we've done it before
well andy's can do all that way better
but they have funding
but of course it's always a risk
especially the games we do because every
game we do
is something totally different obviously
you have co-op and story that is common
to what we do
but the world the characters the
gameplay everything their games have all
been
very different let me tell you it would
blow people's mind actually
i'm ready to hear about it
are you really are you ready can you
handle it that's what i'm telling you
man
next game such a character these guys
have really lost their minds
i mean totally in a good way bring it on
you know we touch on a lot of different
topics uh today
and you know just on the subject of
being an independent studio and the ways
an independent studio can innovate in
maybe ways other studios can't
um just kind of wanted like a real quick
sort of hit
from each one of you on your studios
and like where you want to go in the
future when it comes to
innovation so at hazelite what we want
to push
all the time is combining the story in
the gameplay we pushed out a lot using
the mechanics more and more very
intuitive
big fan used very strongly about that
great unique cool experience that
players haven't played before
now is the time to make something
totally great and unique it's harder in
a movie today because
it's been going on for longer so in a
sense it's a good time to make something
great
you know from valence studios it's you
know our games have come to be
really sort of playing as believing but
playing as believing
is really at the heart of creating
something new an experience that people
really think playing is believing i
haven't seen something like this before
and that's what we want to keep going
okay i feel like we're always looking
for new ways of delivering
story and dialogue and because it's it's
such a diverse industry with so many
different people and
backgrounds and and and ways of thinking
and working
from programmers to artists so i think i
mean that's such a
huge fun inspiring part and why i love
working with games
i was going to say we are so young as a
studio
that i think we're incredibly grateful
for the fact that we get to do
something that we really love i don't
think either of us realized how much we
were going to love
working on this game um working on video
games is wonderful
the unknown let me tell you as far as we
have in
one year i just i'm so excited to see
where it goes yeah i feel like we do
have we do have a voice
and we're still finding our voice and
and and we're
we're growing not only as a studio and
evolving at such a rapid
like pace but we're having fun while
doing it as well and i think it's about
sharing that fun and you know sharing
sharing our experience
our highs and lows and just being open
because again that's
you know that's also part of it right
it's it's about being open about sharing
thank you all very important when these
are concerned
so many questions and playing along and
uh i really appreciate it
everyone's time thank you thank you all
so much thank you cool thanks guys
thank you thank you so much great to be
here with all of you thank you sorry to
took a set thoughts out
so that was all very thoughtful and uh
very inspirational at times
uh thank you for joining us more from
the ea play live spotlight series will
be coming soon there's one more follow
on twitter or go to ea.com for the
latest updates on these games and
everything else from the studio
also remember that ea play live is on
july 22nd
and if you've watched this far you
definitely don't want to miss that
because there will be some exciting news
from
lost and random they're like actually a
playlist
thank you for joining your usual press
conference i think
so much screen flickering look at me go
also i'm sitting so far back
it's just such a weird angle um i
thought this was really neat i'm very
glad that ea did this
um again it just i just want to
highlight it because i think the ea
originals program is just fantastic and
you know i've certainly made plenty of
videos criticizing ea so
very happy to make ones where i talk
about something that they do that i
think is very good
um okay so july 19 is madden probably
not gonna watch that one
fifa next-gen gameplay and there was
something else
we'll see if i can make that work might
be able to make that work um in any case
thank you all for joining me
i appreciate that i'm just gonna pause
it so it doesn't auto play something
else
um figured this would just be a super
chill stream where i ate some carrots
and watermelon
caught up on this really glad they're
doing it love hearing any any uh
devs talk about their work um
watch this week's play watch listen
alright
bye everyone